[Music]
in celebrity professor news submitted by
Fiona Apple Wow what happened a hurt
look I so listen hurts so has new stuff
coming up oh yeah I saw her live
she's alright Matthew McConaughey hey is
now a professor at UT Austin oh wait why
these counties actually been he's been a
professor yeah he has oh but now he's
officially a professor no he's always
been a guest of hotness Oh a
co-instructor Anthony Hopkins I think
was doing that at UC you see I don't
remember Long Beach or something like
that no really I can't remember what
school is but if you see Long Beach
doesn't even exist I'm not usually long
me to see Compton in me no no Cal State
Long Beach yeah that's the one or that's
what USC I can't remember
USC Popeye he was a teacher some parents
don't I would love to learn from someone
that's like a working so this actor this
oscar-winning actor oh yeah been
appointed as a professor of practice at
UT Austin Department of radio television
film and it's no not at UT Blake you
know how to have different satellites
cool yeah exactly it's not one of those
and so but that one's gonna get crowded
real quick so he's there in person it's
all girl the professor there yeah he's
actually teaching a class like he's a
part of the faculty no he used to be a
visiting instructor or he's been that at
UT since 2015 so it's been a minute but
now he actually got appointed as a
professor does that mean he's I'm gonna
do movies anymore because like they take
off like four months maybe during the
summer it's just one semester okay so
like for example he already did a spring
semester and he's gonna do a fall
semester can you imagine it's mainly
fall and spring semesters cuz in fall
2015 you did it fall 2016 spring 2017
spring 2018 oh cool so many people
trying to crash that yeah the waiting
list is insanely long he even said
imagine in this one video he was like
yeah people keep stopping me at the
parking lot trying to see like oh you
bet they're on the waiting
to add the class trying to get yeah so
he graduated from UT from back in 1993
so he wants to give back he's saying
that like a lot of these students remind
them of himself and they have a lot of
the same questions he did when he
started because he did study like film
you know and so he were just like yeah
you know it's just really cool I was
wishing it would be some like thing you
would never expect like nating or
something you know
teachers and knitting yeah you just sit
there and you knit with that waitlist
would still be super long I would love
to yeah no no I can talk man so it's at
Moody College of Communication is what
it's called so moody there Longhorn you
here's a video
look I know from me when I was in film
school I thought being a film director
was a dictatorship and I was intimidated
by not having the right answer to
everything
oh I go work on days confused for three
weeks I'm like oh you don't have to have
the answer to everything
yeah you're still directing where the
film goes but you don't have to have an
answer to everything you can be open to
being inspired you can be open to a PA
having a good idea and try it out you
can be open to actors having a different
good idea that maybe it wasn't what you
saw but it's the truth for them and is
still true for your scene felt with it
like the awesome collaboration a book
that's how it is officer turned here
like I said oh what turned he know his
directing Sal cuz he's very like this is
my I like the script like he writes
literally every single movement and
that's that's how you can tell directing
is [ __ ]
because there's no right way and you can
say that about everything yeah only
sports only sports is not yeah whoops
not everything there's a different style
right like for business ownership you
know like the CEO has they all have to a
different style of leadership yeah he
was saying in the same video because
this was just a little clip of a longer
video but in that the rest of the video
he ends up saying like you know that I'm
when I was in film school I thought that
I would be meeting a director and seeing
like wow like this is this is how they
do their magic and he said like he's out
of all the films he's worked on he's
never met a single
director that gave him that like that's
the magic that's the formula that's a
spark that's in that director because he
said everyone has their own styles and
everyone ends up figuring out how
they're gonna create this product that
ends up going out to the public but
there is no magic sauce like I guess it
goes to show that's why like it's a
creative field mystic probably saying it
like being an author or writing
everybody has their way of doing it and
they're like their way of making it
successful let the public tell you that
you suck I think that's I think that's
how you win or lose or know if you're
good some extent I think it was good
[ __ ] that doesn't go anywhere
mm-hmm and vice versa there's some
really shitty things that get bought and
sold and stuff it's actually the
shittiest thing they get - all the most
like fast and furious or Hobbs and Shaw
like and then like the Oscar winners I
don't know learning to appeal to an
audience maybe you have bad taste
because I like fast and furious okay
what number one to do stick to the bench
one is better than watching [ __ ] Vin
Diesel get married in a tank top is like
the best thing that happened to me like
it was such a serious scene - everyone
was like they're like oh my god dude
they're finally getting married and I'm
like I think we were the only track you
know I think cuz I'm like is that the
one worried they've jumped over the
freeway yeah that was rigged and
everyone was like whoa and we're like ha
ha ha and we're like oh [ __ ] wait this
is not the funny part are we doing what
going back to the right thing I mean
ending you're saying appealing to an
audience and stuff what are some things
that you've learned in your field
because you obviously appeal to the
masses in your craft it's like even when
it comes to streaming it's really hard
to balance between being who you want to
be and kind of like being this on-screen
character that people probably like kind
of want you to be mmm and there's
certain people that the way that they go
about it is just like splitting that up
like there's a guy whose name's doctor
disrespect and he just full-on has
basically a character that he plays on
stream which is like this really macho
like gamer guy yeah and it's like a
great character but he also like has a
different name for that character
and sometimes it's like I feel like
there isn't SuperDuper aligned between
like poking me in the person and like me
the person so that's kind of hard to
navigate yeah just trying to figure out
like do you want to be a character or do
you want to just be yourself online just
being a character that's the easiest way
to appeal to an audience but then you
kind of have to change who you are
mm-hmm that's how you get typecast but
they say in the beginning if you're not
getting typecast you're not getting cast
you have to feel is something specific -
even though the camp yeah so well for me
like it was it's like you know you grow
right and so you started when you were
really young you're 17 9 23 so I started
acting when I was or I started acting
when I was 8 but I started acting
professionally like going that route
like serious when I was like 18 and I
was just being me and I was doing
stand-up and stuff as me but then the
casting orders were like mm-hmm well we
don't know where to put you and so then
my acting coach like helped me like be
more like that like like ditzy like
character and like that got me booked on
a lot of stuff and that but then it was
like I had to be that all the time and
people treated me like I was really did
see it when they met me in real life and
stuff in it became like this jail cell
where I was like I can't beat that well
yeah I'm tired of using my sexuality to
get ahead - yeah I'm always like this is
you getting like I feel like I I'm
always telling out by you know like yes
being object yeah I just want to like be
known for my like brains like in like
I'm just so tired of it you know but
then I'm so stuck because I don't know
what else to do emanating sex all the
time yeah it's hard for people it's hard
must be rough I just want people to know
that like I'm really not that much of a
ho you know like I have a brain and I
can talk and think but like I just see
you as a ho I know but it's my fault
though cuz I put that out there you know
and then like I thrive like the
attention just makes me feel awesome but
that's what like that's what got your
start it is and how do I leave that like
how do I you're dictating this for like
this actual for sure actually
we have a same dialogue yeah for real
like how do you stop that though how do
you change the game like I want to be
known for like my thoughts well people
just don't know who you are but you
known for being a thought oh I don't
know the quality of celebrities you want
professor [ __ ] yeah hello intimidating
too because I'm like oh it kinda reminds
me I'm not trotting [ __ ] them for good
grades that's a win-win situation you
[ __ ] Matthew McConaughey and you get the
good grades unless you [ __ ] bad oh did
he give you a seat I was gonna say like
it reminds me of when I first started
with you guys and then I started getting
like some sort of following but then
like people that I would look up to or
get intimidated by and then they would
follow me I would think about them and
get really self-conscious when I'm gonna
post something cuz they're gonna see it
oh even open up their Instagram that day
girl I mean you know how self-absorbed
[Music]
world revolves around me Joe hello
so that's what I would get really
intimidated and so the so thinking of
having Matthew McConaughey as my
professor I could see how it's really
anytime you write like you do an
assignment you're like you can't see
this [ __ ] now I can see that being
intimidated so long adjust your
professor yeah it's someone you really
look up to as long his office and he's
like wrote this tip don't real [ __ ]
death every homework assignment I turn
it up spray a little bit of perfume on
it oh my god tell me totally fun ok
paper yeah I liked when girls did that
when they would write letters and they
spray things and I would smell that and
I'm like [ __ ] were you in jail
Spray [ __ ] yeah cuz you didn't have game
I didn't in gay baby this is all the
game I need it right here and everything
that was a big thing that we did in
junior high even with friends and class
no [ __ ] knows
oh hey see you never had a crush like in
junior high and then you would write to
each other and you get each other's
adversity I didn't shave my legs pluck
my eyebrows laughter sure was not
wearing perfume have this going on yeah
it was like having the kiss with the
lipstick on the letter and I would kiss
that on the paper
Wow my boy write me notes but it would
smell like cigarettes okay that's the
man sing with the cool boy you're
popular no we quit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]